ladies and gentlemen good morning I'm
very pleased and very honored to be with
you this morning in this so beautiful
Marseille I would like to thank the
board of the TTH consul Europe for
giving me the great opportunity to
present the digital agency and
especially as a French Broadband Plan to
so prestigious audience well the French
digital agency is a quite new
administrative body within the French
Ministry of Economy we are a dedicated
team of about 40 people relatively young
as you can see and we try to design
implement and develop different kinds of
initiatives with one goal in mind
helping our country to achieve
successful digital transformation we are
closely connected to the local public
authorities and to the private digital
ecosystems why Baker's first we design
each of how a program from local
successful experiences we can identify
in some part of the country we design
our program by the local experiences
feedbacks and it's clearly a bottom-up
method and secondly because the
implementation of all our programs fully
depends on the action and the
coordination of both private ecosystem
and local public authorities the French
little agency is like a band master a
football team coach we do not play the
game we only give strategic orientations
we organize we plan we coordinate the
different actors we can help them with
some toolboxes or sometimes with
some subsidies to help initiating a
movement but the players or the local
authorities Zeo patrols industrial
companies the entrepreneurs but not the
state to achieve these goals the agency
initiative abides in three main and
complementary programs the first one is
called the French tech initiative and we
present by the rate origami booster and
the French tech initiative supports a
startup ecosystem to help them becoming
international champions
let me tell you let some few words about
this French tech initiative first we try
to federate to cluster together they're
entrepreneurs as well in a geographical
perspective for example we have 13 main
regional herbs called metropolitan check
like in Marseille for example as well in
a more sectoral somatic perspective for
example elf tech IOT find FinTech or
even foot tech yes we are in France and
the goal is to create links between
these local and sectoral entrepreneurs
to help them share their experience as
recipes are tricks to go faster
secondly we encourage the acceleration
of this and we the acceleration of the
scallop of this startup for example
providing them fast-track chemists
relative procedures and wider public
phones 200 million euro to co-invest
with private investors in the main
success story
it's a French tech acceleration fund and
thirdly we promote the international
development of these startups all around
the world for example with the network
of 22 international apps where
entrepreneurs can find some help to
discover to enter to penetrate some new
markets and we also develop different
programs to facilitate as implementation
of a new startup foreign
startup in France but we are also
convinced that the new digital
revolution is not only for a close group
of happy new aware people we do think
that everyone every citizen should have
the opportunity to discover to
understand to appropriate these new
digital services that's the goal of the
second Department of the digital
agencies a digital society program which
aims to make friends and includes even
innovative digital Republic by promoting
skills for everyone
digital skills for everyone says program
is relatively new only few months but we
are surely facing a huge and very
important issue because there is a big
risk of digital factor by Z as the
appropriation of services new services
but let come to the French superfast
broadband plan the third Department of
the agency but it's important to
consider this plan into the different
action of the different missions of the
digital agency this plan was launched in
spring 2013 my the President of the
Republic with one goal give every arm
every business a very fast broadband
access it means more than 30 megabit per
second by the end of 2020 to the
challenge we faced at this time was
really huge first of all because France
was very poorly ranking ranking in terms
of connectivity with only 27% of very
fast broadband coverage that is lower
than
the European average and secondly
because the a big Quito's a
characteristic of this plan 100-person
coverage was really how to say that
tricky and really hard to to achieve
because usually a networks are deployed
progressively from the main city to
reveal area for example the classic the
historical telephonic networks start to
be deployed in Paris by the end of the
19th century in 1878 for the Universal
Exposition in Paris and it took more
than a century to deploy the COPO
telecommunication network throughout the
world country so with this plan
launching in 2013 the challenge was to
deploy new networks in the same time or
a similar time both in the urban and in
the rural area so to do so we design a
plan in order to organize the deployment
and organize a very huge 10 years 20
billion euros investment so we involve
all the stakeholders of the ecosystem in
the plan local public local authorities
of course operators industrial companies
investor private and public investor and
we gather this full mobilization and we
try for in the first step to clarify the
playground and we we had a great chance
at this moment because the rain national
regulator national regulatory authority
had just finished there its regulatory
framework promoting coin
basement mutualization on one network
sharing by different operators so it was
exactly the time to cry fine the
playground and to ask operators private
purchase what they won't do to do and we
launched a public call to ask private
operators where they can take
commitments for next generation access
deployments by the end of 2020 and
within exigence of complete and coherent
deployment in area and the result of
this consultation was that too many
operators the incumbent origin also s
affair the main challenger which
responded that they can take commitments
in three sir in three thousand six
androids municipalities it means it's
the most three androids men urban areas
with ftth technology by the end of 2020
so just after we launched a call for
projects to in order to subsidize a
public project from local public
authority to deploy complementary
networks in the rural area the
commitments of public private operators
we present v between 55 and 57 percent
of the population in terms of technology
we were quite not all we receive the
commitments of the private operators to
deploy ftth networks it was a good
News and in the rural areas we let the
local public authority make the choice
and depending of course of their budget
and their orientation political
orientation the national agency only
challenge as the public the local public
authority Authority choices but to in
order to to to estimate the cost for the
state subsidies this local public
projects we assess at this time that in
rural area we would have a 50-person of
FTTH deployment 35% very fast broadband
with F TTC and fiber to the cabinet
switch cabinet and between 10 and 15
person with while wireless access but
actually the result is that local public
authority clearly prefer FTTH technology
in comparison with other why because
they mainly assess that they they prefer
to pay one time to invest in a long term
30 years or more then pay less invest
less but in with the perspective of new
investment in few years so where we are
now this is the high-speed broadband
coverage as you can see we were very ban
will still are not very good but it's
what is important is that we are we have
a very little advance in comparison with
our
initial forecast which is the line above
in terms of ftth marketable premises in
as you can see the dynamic is clearly on
the commercial area in where the public
private sorry private operators to
commitments but the work we have made
this three years with all the local
authority will produce effective
consequences and a progression in
increase in terms of ftth marketable
premises in rural areas progressively
for in the national footprint we have
[Music]
this is the increase I have to teach
marketable premises so as you can see in
2014 with only 1 million ftg premises
connected and this year in 2016 and last
year in 2016 we double this with twice
than in in 2014 with 2 Millions
premises marketable and as you can see
the increase in the future will be
support essentially by non commercial
areas because the problem is when you
prepare a public project you need
several mounts and even several years
between the moment you take the decision
to invest in FTTH ROI in a very fast
Network and the delivery of the first
premises but it when with all the
projects we we have already accepted and
financed we are sure that in the next
few years and especially in the five new
year's next years we will have
an important increase of the deployment
of
ftth premises in rural areas okay I'm
very late so I'm go well there is my
point of view four main keys points in
the French Broadband Plan first is that
we have a very close public private
partnership with the operators and with
the ASP the plan was designed with the
operators and it's no account plan so we
had to clarify and to define very
precisely the frontier between the
commercial and non-commercial areas with
contract between operators state and
local public authority of course all
this commitment are based on soft low of
soft power because actually we do not
have contracts with penalty if the
operators do not respect their
commitments but for the moment it works
and we are monitoring very precisely the
ongoing deployment so but we have just
one point in mind is how we can protect
public initiative area and public
English projects from cherry picking
deployments from private operators for
the moment there is no case of this risk
but for us it's a preoccupation it's an
issue that we important for us so the
second key point is we made a
public-private partnership with
industrial and investors because when
you have a big plan with many local
public services you have to define
architectural and technical
standardization to lower the cost
and lower the cost of construction and
maintenance and the quality of
maintenance in the time we have to give
a profitability on the rate of
deployments to the industry to adapt the
Quad Cities the capacity and the
investment to prevent the sold out risk
and of course we have to plan the
management of job and skill forecasts in
terms of manpower to deploy all this
infrastructure third key point is that
we are we add and we have a close
coordination with the national
regulatory authority this is a strong
point that we have a regulatory
framework very very stable design and
this is important for give to give
incentive for private and public
investment because the regulator
organized a structural metal addition
with the co investment that involve all
the operators in the plan like lunch or
ice affair when they build the networks
not as a leader but also for weak
telecom are free for example the
challenges who can Co invest in these
new networks and of course we had a pro
investment competitive regulation an
equilibrium between incentives of
investment and protecting from barriers
to entry and fourth we have a
transparent mentoring because this plan
is a marathon it's a very long run plan
so we have to inform the population to
inform as a public authority where we
are and how the plan is working with a
large front transparency so we have
online a website with all the deployment
each not each month but I think it's
three months well my conclusion I think
that
the plan is clearly FTTH oriented not
exclusively focused but clearly FTTH
oriented because we only subsidy fibre
who can
well fiber when is this ftth no problem
when it's fiber for fgetc we want to be
sure that the this investment could
mainly be reinvest for ftth reused for
ftth future networks I think that FTTH
is not only a question of off speed I
really don't like very fast broadband
plan because it's not only a question of
speed because our really Singh and we
see it each day more that fgts is a more
equation of quality stability and
liability which is absolutely strategic
for new public services like he else
working from home or maintaining seniors
at home and that's why the French plan I
want to be a big quittez it's because
this infrastructures are only supports
for new public services and if we
exclude some part of the population from
this infrastructure we will exclude them
from part of these new public services
and at least but at last but not least
we we do think that ftth well can
guarantee a pro-competitive framework
and competition is the condition for
innovation and descriptive new services
and with an FTTH regulatory framework
very Pro competitive very open we are
sure to promote innovation and new
services I'm not sure it is always the
case with fibre to the cabinet
although networks not so open and not so
open to to innovation so that's why we
have a clear plan oriented ftth oriented
and as you may know we have national
election of the next president of the
Republic in May and the next president
will have to make the choice to define
what's next after the plan 2022 and
probably surely be the question of the
wall the deployment of liquid whose FTTH
networks in all the the country thank
you for your attention and three for
being late and one thank you very much
for that very insightful um
Ultron's going to take a seat and we're
gonna have some Q&A and quickly
afterwards and before we kick off can I
see a show of hands for the Twitter
users in the audience please quite a few
excellent well guys just by way of
reminder we do have a Twitter feed at
hashtag ask FTTH so if you want to
submit your questions please do so for
the Q&A sessions that we're going to
have here with Antoine and with our next
speaker as well um it gives me great
pleasure now to welcome onboard onto the
stage our new director general and
there's a bet fitori please give her a
warm welcome to our Isabel
[Music]
thank you very much Ronan and thank you
very much Antoine for it a really
interesting overview of the French model
in particular you've mentioned that
there are regulatory changes and indeed
there is a major review of European
legislation as part of that there is
also a proposal to strengthen the role
of national regulatory authorities and
their cooperation I wonder whether you
have any additional ideas how
cooperation on the promotion of very
high capacity networks could be
strengthened is there anything else that
authorities could do beyond national
regulatory authorities well it's clear
that we face a very complicated in risky
challenge or many challenges so we need
and we face a very moving environment in
terms of Technology framework and we
really have to be fine connected with
the environment with the ecosystem and
from my point of view I I can regret
that we were - we were national focused
only on France and we share just a
little bit with other national digital
agency or similar organizations and I
think it could be a good idea to think
about how the different body
administrative body in charge of digital
innovation digital transformation
deployment of new infrastructure could
have a structure for example like the
barrack in in terms of regulatory
frameworks
I think it's important to have to share
information to exchange experiences to
lower the risk of implementation of this
huge challenges Thank You Anton quick
question for you with regard to the new
targets that are being put forward
particularly as part of the aspirations
for gigabit society within Europe the
new targets that have been set down of
gigabit connectivity to all
socio-economic drivers and 100 megabits
connectivity to everybody how realistic
is that for France given the initiatives
that you guys have underway at the
moment
well the main issue is is it realistic
for rural areas but as I just mentioned
the project the issue is not only of
question of networks but it's a question
of what all the new services will go on
these networks and if you think about
working at home about health about
education you can imagine new services
which need a very very high level of
quality of liability not only speed and
clearly France and made a choice to take
the risk to be in advance which
represent a cost because we absolutely
do not want to be late in terms of
infrastructure facing these new services
so I think it's it's not a question of
technical possibilities of course it's
realistic we can deploy ftth networks
everywhere but the question is what
choice political politicals want to make
facing the challenge well
France had made this choice there is to
be an advance
the race to go too fast and it's not an
evidence and last week or last month the
Supreme Court who is which is
controlling public subsidies record
account tallest you go too fast you go
too far you better made a mix of
different technologies and less ftth
networks deployment in the rural area
but I think it's really a political
choice do we want to take the risk to be
late for the news services that we even
do not know today okay and maybe we've
time for one quick question from the
Twitter feed there's a better one - yes
I think there is a very quick one indeed
what about for the digital agency to
leave Paris for a more rural area and
use digital technologies to work
differently than today of course yeah
great and I don't know if the mayor of
Marseille is still here but maybe could
made a suggestion make a suggestion well
actually it's not very easy for us but
we we can think about it especially in
the South of France but Cerny and
excellent well ladies and gentlemen
please give a warm round of applause for
antoine his insights have been very
badly
you